the jurogan experience
and nobody quite knows okay
who is it that inherited it and there
are those people who say
hey this wasn't ross that ordered these
hits you know this was like nobody knows
who's behind the keys at the time
anything has happened so there are those
people who
who completely deny you know his family
completely denies the culpability and
who knows we'll never know
that is a problem when you're dealing
with corrupt cops too right like they
literally could have faked
him doing that we don't know
what has he denied that he called hits
we should explain to people that haven't
seen the film
spoiler alert uh it goes off the rails
for ross for young ross
and uh at one point in time one of his
the guy he's working with
gets busted and rats him out and then
the cops are using that guy's account
and communicating with him and he orders
a hit on that guy
and the guy gets to see it and it's like
holy [ __ ] i can't believe this
who knows how much of that is real and
how much is not
but the problem is you're dealing with
corrupt cops
and if the corrupt cops wanted to frame
him for something that's going to put
him away for a long time
just running the website and allowing
people a portal
where they can do this and sell things
is not quite good enough
but if you can get a guy to literally
call for murder not once but twice then
you've really got him locked up we don't
know though
did he deny that he called those well
and not only not only did he deny it
but um what happened was so so to back
up a step basically
the the corrupt cop you know in the
movie the corrupt cop at a certain point
sets out to bust ross and then as at a
certain point he's like
kind of getting [ __ ] blocked by his
superiors and whatever and so he's
he says okay i'm going to rip this kid
off instead if i can't bust him i'm
going to steal the money and i'm going
to use it for my own purposes
but what ends up happening is and all of
that information by the way
the the fake murder of his employee and
the photographs that were taken of it
all that stuff is true that's all in the
real story and as we're shooting the
movie we have access to the actual
faked murder photos where what does it
look like it looks like it's available
online can we see it
yeah it's available online oh we need to
see that right now see if you can find
the
curtis clark green uh murder photos fake
murder photos
what was his uh online name chronic pain
appropriately enough did he look like
that guy the fat guy with the creature
he does and i love that and that actor
is amazing amazing
he was in uh eastwood put him in um
richard jewell
and he was in spike lee's last movie um
he's just
he's one of those guys richard jewell
yeah he played richard jewell and he's
fantastic
really good i mean he seemed like the
quintessential
internet couch monster working with that
guy was so fun you know because like
again we had the you know we had
information about the real guy and what
happened was when that guy gets busted
when chronic pain
gets busted in this article it said he
had a chihuahua and the chihuahua's
going
bat [ __ ] barking crazy as the feds are
kicking in the door or whatever
and we're sitting there and i'm thinking
like man chihuahua going bat [ __ ] on set
that's going to screw up the dialogue
what do we do so i'm talking to paul and
paul's like
what if we give him a ferret instead and
i'm like ferret dude let's go
ferret you know and then the other the
other brilliant thing that paul did was
he said you know all of this like you
know all this online chatter where it's
you know you're typing on the computer
and then the other person types back
he's like
what if the dude's a mumbler so he's
kind of saying this [ __ ] out loud the
whole time that he's talking and he
starts talking to himself so once he had
the ferret and made the guy a mumbler
he had like the keys to the character um
yeah
he nailed it it was great everything
down to the fanny pack it was beautiful
the um the the so the dialogue between
all the dialogue that you show on on
screen was actually real dialogue
yeah so in the movie you have
ross calling for this guy's
murder did did you struggle with that at
all
if ross says he never did that and he
believe
did what what was his theory well i
think
okay so there's a couple of important
points one is the feds never charged him
with attempted murder
they put it you know ross ended up
getting sentenced to
two life sentences plus 40 years without
the possibility of parole
and this is a crazy fact which is
considerably harsher
than what el chapo was sentenced to
right jesus christ
and so they really you know
they threw the book at this guy and
buried him and yeah for a plea
he had he did he was offered a deal at a
certain point and he turned it down
because i think it was 10 years jesus
christ kid
i know and that well and here this is a
crazy so this is a crazy story so
starting out with
um you know you had asked me if i had
reached out to him so i reached out to
him when he was locked up in mcc new
york awaiting sentencing
and then all the way through he was
hoping to you know
waiting the case was working its way
through the appeals process
so um and then finally he was hoping
that trump was going to pardon him and
there was a big kind of hullabaloo okay
is trump going to pardon this pardon him
on his last day in office
and he didn't and i will and i was
sitting there watching the news waiting
to see if he would and i woke up the
next day
and i was like man i'm going to look i'm
going to look it up and so i went on to
the bureau of prison's website
and i typed in ross's name and it comes
up you know tucson penitentiary
and then it said release date colon
life and it just like it hit me you know
this kid's 36 years old he's 10 years
younger than i am
and just staring down the barrel of that
and so
i sat down even though the movie's you
know coming out or whatever at the time
and i decide you know what i owe this
guy and some fun like just
human being man to man so i write him a
letter and i said listen man
i've made this movie and this is my
portrait of you
and my portrait of your story and of
silk road
um and it's you know it's coming out
into the world but if you ever want to
tell your version of the story
in any form or fashion you want to do it
as a rolling stone interview
you want to do it as a documentary you
want to do it any way you want
you tell me and i will be there in
person to sit down with you because i do
feel like there's some kind of
i don't know i guess like spiritual
contract between me and him like when
you enter into a story like this
you're you're in somebody else's life in
a real way
yeah we it's almost like we do
need to hear his version of it right
and we don't we just and especially
when you're dealing with lawyers in a
court case where it's
you know they're withholding some
testimony if they think it'd be
detrimental to his case or
you know once all said and done i wonder
why trump didn't pardon him
i don't know and then who knows you know
the way it was reported
that um he was closely considering it
um but in the kind of last days of the
you know chaotic into the administration
or whatever it didn't happen
but i was i was you know because no
matter what you think of
ross's politics or what he did as
a you know or silk road even
there is this thing where like i'm a
believer in second chances man you know
i've screwed up a million things in my
lifetime
and um
and i feel like somebody like that
hopefully has something to give
the world you know and isn't thrown away
it's just crazy that they were
offering him 10 years and instead they
gave him two life sentences plus 40
years
with no possibility of parole like why
you know there's this there's such a
disparity well it's
i think in some way or another it was
like this changed the drug war right it
changed the way the drug game
happened and it changed the way the drug
war was fought suddenly
it's like it's almost an existential
threat to the drug war
when it's not by busts and hand to hand
and all the street stuff that we've seen
you know
since you know nixon unleashes dea you
know in 73 or whatever the year is
suddenly it's wait a minute all
happening online anonymous
dhl usps people are delivering it nobody
even knows that they're carrying it so
it was like
it was an existential threat to the us
government to
the dea to the drug war and so he got
the book thrown at him
crazy so what was the motivation for
offering him 10 years as a plea
you know i don't know and and i wonder
you know looking back on it it's always
kind of hindsight is 2020 but he had
been
beating the system for a long time right
he was like
one dude with a laptop that unleashed
this thing that kind of metastasized and
went over the whole world
and um and he was winning
for a while he was ahead of the feds he
was ahead of the u.s attorney's office
he had chuck schumer there you know
calling for his head
and yet he continued to kind of game the
system and beat him by just being
nimble and being able to throw his
laptop and his backpack and roll on to
the next location
so maybe you know maybe he thought he'd
be able to continue beating the system i
don't know god
just i mean i just
he'd be out he'd be out he'd be out now
full 10 years later well and the crazy
thing you know we did this two hours ago
kind of convenient i put silk road on
the top
sorry on the tor network about 10 years
ago i've been thinking about
what was going through the mind of my 26
year old self back then in 2011.
so much has changed if only i could turn
back time
wow so he's got a twitter account catch
new episodes of the joe rogan experience
for free
only on spotify watch back catalog
jre videos on spotify including clips
easily seamlessly switch between video
and audio experience on spotify you can
listen to the jre
in the background while using other apps
and can download episodes to save on
data cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode of the joe rogan experience